au pays de ces fiers éleveurs tout est
payant
l'industrie touristique est passée par
là et a perverti jusqu'à l'âme d'un
peuple
[Musique]
ces guerriers qui incarnait la
quintessence de la beauté africaine se
sont transformés parfois en bête de
foire que les vacanciers visitent comme
un zoo humain
tout autour du parc de masaï mara de
faux village ont été construits nous
décidons d'en visiter un est à peine
sorti de la voiture le comité d'accueil
nous demandent de l'argent
il ya un droit d'entrée pour aller
danser il a gelé ses 20 $ par personne
5 minutes c'est très cher on veut juste
jeter un coup d'oeil ce peut être
acheter des souvenirs
c'est comme ça il faut payer le tarif on
est le prix c'est
ses 20 $ par personne
aucune possibilité de négocier nous
payons donc les 20 dollars pour avoir
juste le droit d'entrer à l'intérieur
nous tombons sur une représentation un
peu étrange des femmes habillées en
tenue de cérémonie danse pour les
touristes une jeune femme blanche les
imite un peu gauche mans devant sa
famille qui l'a filmé ces vacanciers
sont des américains visiblement ça ne
les choque pas de devoir payer pour ce
folklore bidonné
tout à fait oui on a payé aussi pour ce
village ça n'a rien à voir avec l'entrée
du parti il paraît qu'il ya d'autres
villages pas défaut comme ici dix
authentiques traditionnels on n'est pas
obligé de payer pour les visiter
non non non il faut payer à chaque fois
allez venez avec moi je vais vous
montrer nos maisons nos questions met
visiblement mal à l'aise les massaï qui
font tout pour nous séparer mais nous
continuons de suivre la famille
américaine après la danse c'est le
moment de passer à l'étape achat sur des
stands bricoler toute une série d'objets
typiquement masai il y a de tout des
colliers des bracelets des statuettes
bref de quoi satisfaire le touriste il
ya même des dents et des griffes
authentique de lyon mais là attention ce
commerce est illégal heureusement le
vendeur sait comment tromper les
autorités de son pays
vous avez pour la douane à l'aéroport je
suis pas sûr d'abord
si vous avez un petit sac à dos vous le
cacher à l'intérieur
et il ne fait rien chaque nom ils
vérifient jamais
ces pseudos villages et leurs massaï
parlant parfaitement anglais voilà tout
ce que voit la plupart des touristes
pendant leur safari
steve nous propose de s'enfoncer sur
quelques kilomètres dans la brousse de
quitter les pistes principales pour
découvrir la vraie culture masai il a
grandi ici il connaît tout le monde
un groupe d'hommes en armes nous attend
le chef c'est celui qui tient une lance
il nous confirme que son village n'a
jamais accueilli d'étrangers jusqu'à
présent
il dit que c'est un village traditionnel
il n'a pas été construit pour les
touristes ils ne reçoivent jamais
d'étrangers chez eux c'est pour ça qu'il
faut leur demander avant l'autorisation
de venir alors que les femmes
s'approchent steve nous brief sur ce que
l'on peut faire et ne pas faire les code
de politesse massaï sont très précis
quand vous entrez dans le village vous
devez saluer tout le monde les enfants
vont d'approcher leur tête toucherait de
la main pour les femmes vous devez juste
dire bonjour de loin
des sept sports tu appartiens à cet
homme le chef il y a plusieurs entrées
dans le village on l'abat unis sir
celle là c'est celle du chef
les masaï sont avant tout des éleveurs
mais aussi des guerriers réputés pour
leur bravoure
encore aujourd'hui il leur arrive de
tuer des lions pour protéger leur
village voici les derniers trophées des
dents qu'il garde précieusement car
quand il tue un lion ils le font juste
avec leurs lances
il explique que pour commencer ils
encerclent le yoyo quand le lion devient
suffisamment agressif la tac avec leurs
lances
mais il ne la jette jamais sur lui ils
attendent le dernier moment pour la
planter directement dans le coeur du
bien
mais aujourd'hui ces firmes à ça ils
risquent de perdre leur mode de vie
ancestral
car même sont sur le point de tout
abandonner pour se consacrer au tourisme
à leurs yeux c'est leur seul moyen de
survivre
ce serait parfait si les touristes
pouvaient venir les voir
mais leur village est très loin des
pistes et personne ne vient jamais pour
eux ce serait une bénédiction
d'accueillir des touristes comme
ça les aiderait tellement
pour l'instant ils ne vivent qu'à
indirectement du tourisme
les souvenirs cachette les vacanciers
c'est ici qu'ont les fabriquent mais ce
ne sont pas ces masai qui les vendent
chaque jour les femmes doivent produire
des dizaines de colliers et bracelets
que les autres villages plus proche du
parc vendront pour quelques euros à 6 en
plein soleil elle passe des heures à
travailler pour seulement quelques
centimes d'euros c'est bien insuffisant
pour faire vivre le village
c'est trop loin des zones touristiques
c'est impossible pour eux de faire
l'aller retour dans la journée jusqu'à
masaï mara
ils ne peuvent pas commercialiser eux
mêmes leur artisanat
pour l'instant c'est ma sai servent donc
de petites mains pour ceux qui sont en
contact direct avec les étrangers ils
continuent de vivre dans leur maison
traditionnelle fête de bouse de vache et
c'est pour cela qu'il ya autant de
mouches ici
à l'intérieur quasiment pas de lumière
pas de meubles rien juste un feu qui
rend l'air irrespirable
dans la seule pièce on vit à une dizaine
toutes générations confondues et on dort
sur une simple peau de vache l'année
[Musique]
la vie est dure chez les massaï une vie
que notre guide steve ne renie pas
j'ai passé la moitié de ma vie dans une
maison comme celle là
ça m'a donné l'opportunité de connaître
parfaitement la culture de mes ancêtres
et de comprendre et d'apprécier aussi
d'où je viens
je ne regrette rien et je suis très fier
d'être un masaï
[Applaudissements]
la fierté c'est ce qu'il reste au peuple
massaï si chère à steve les multiples
sécheresse et la crise économique qui
touche le kenya les place dans une
situation très fragile
la solution existe pourtant il faudrait
qu'ils puissent profiter plus de
l'argent que les touristes dépensent
dans le parc une manne financière qui
leur échappe en grande partie
et
il y aurait des reines